well there are there are certain um
there are certainly uh
things that have followed on from the
fact that um well what should we say um
the woke uh the awake the awokened um do
not see themselves as christians see
themselves as having emancipated
themselves from christianity um because
there that there are um
certain um impulses i think within human
nature that christianity has served to
kind of bit and bridle and um the
one of them actually is is the category
of original sin which i think ties into
what you're alluding to original sin is
is is absolutely the category of people
in the 60s you know who who came to
reject christianity really hated you
know it was everything the hippies were
not about the idea that we were all
infected by sin because adam and eve
fell you know absolute no no and so
it came to seem
you know in the tune with the the the
60s spirit progressive spirit um
that we're all born free um you know
we're not born with original sin and and
that seems you know i mean he wouldn't
want to sign up to that but the cr
i think that we now see the the the
implications of that because
it turns out that original sin is a very
democratic
doctrine because it means that we're all
sinners
we've all got fault
and one of one of the issues i think
with with um with what's happening is
that there are large numbers of of of
people who don't feel that they're
sinners who feel that they're liberated
um and and ultimately this goes back to
um and you see this is why i love
ancient history
it goes back to the 5th century a.d of
course it does
and it goes back to an argument between
two theologians pelagius who was this
great burly britain the very first
british intellectual that we know of
who argued that it was possible for
christians to become perfect through
their own agency so you could
you know if you're sufficiently virtuous
you can attain heaven through your own
agency
uh and against this you have augustine
um
this kind of glowing brilliant
north african bishop who says no we are
all saturated in sin we're steeped in
sin we cannot get to heaven through our
own agency we depend on the on the grace
of god because we're all sinners and
it's it's augustine's doctrine that wins
out plagiarism becomes a heretic
um
and
the 60s is a pelagian movement because
it's saying no we can become perfect you
know this is the age of aquarius we can
you know we can uh
become virtuous through our own agency
and i think
that the the great awokening is a
pelagian movement it feels that that it
is possible for people to become
virtuous and become perfect but the the
problem with that
for
is that
if you are convinced of your own virtue
if you're convinced of your own
rectitude and you are convinced that it
is possible to become perfect
then that means that you are in a
position to sit in moral judgment on
those who haven't
and i think that that that is what um
that's what what a lot of people who who
who find a certain quality of um
moral
self-satisfaction in
the awokened
i think that that's what they feel and i
think that what they're feeling what
they're reacting to is the pelagian
quality of it they're augustinian
without knowing it well the other
problem of course and you make a great
point the other problem of course with
that mindset is that anyone who has
failed to become perfect is therefore
not
ordinarily human but actually is morally
deficient in some way yes that's another
factor but look francis and i have
have expressed a lot of concerns about
what we've described here as the work
movement woke people uh might say that
being described as work is a sort of
slanderous term that it's
inappropriately applied and i i wanted
to put the counterpoint uh playing
devil's advocate somewhat you've charted
the historical context of all of this
all the way from the papacy
in the 11th century the protestant
reformation the enlightenment and so on
these are all you know great strides in
human history even the french revolution
massive bloodbath does end feudalism and
we move into a sort of new uh new world
that we're all happy to live in so are
we sort of me francis and everyone else
who sort of opposes the woke stuff are
we these crusty old
uh
you know
mine and nobles in revel pre-revolution
in france who are sort of about to
witness our own demise and that's why we
hate it well is that where we are
i mean looking behind this is the idea
that of of progress
and moral progress so progressivism and
and and people very rarely stop to think
well you know why do we have this idea
um
why do we assume that there's some kind
of moral arc that's going forwards i
think it's very hard wise well because
uh because of well i would say and
you'll correct me no doubt very shortly
but i would say it's because
as we look into the last millennium
that's what we've seen as we're looking
at two
broadly speaking
that's what we've seen but but but um i
mean we we can talk about technical
progress yeah but the idea of moral
progress you know where does that come
from uh why why do we now think that um
say slavery is wrong or whatever um
and again it's it's it's
fundamentally comes down to christian
theology and this is the weird thing
that i've cut you know i really didn't
begin with any particular interest in
christianity i had no particular
interest in theology and the kind of
dawning
realization
looking at the classical world the
pre-christian world contemplating how
different it was how strange how many
assumptions they had that seemed totally
alien to me and i think where do these
ideas come from and always it's kind of
like you know trying to find an itch on
your back and then you you get to it you
scratch it it's so good that's kind of
what it's like is that is that
strange theological ideas that cropped
up in it centuries often millennia ago
continue to reverberate through it's
like it was it keens you said that that
people who think they've got radical new
ideas that are always in hock to some
defunct economist well
our society we're in
we're in hock to some defunct theologian
invariably and and the idea of progress
lies in the notion that is um basically
goes all the way back to paul
that there is a law of god
and for the jews the law of god is
written you know on the tablets that
got given to moses that in turn got
given to the children of israel
paul says no actually the law of god is
written on the heart
and how do we know
what that law of god is well the spirit
illumines it and enables us to read it
and the further quality of that is that
the more we read it
the better we become at understanding
what it is
and in turn
unlike um uh say islam which inherits
from um from from from uh the jews the
idea that you have a mass body of law
that comes directly from god and
therefore kind of is eternally extant
christians have always thought that the
law is illumined by the spirit therefore
humans can legitimately author that and
law itself will become progressive
because over the course of time human
understanding of um of of what god's law
is will become better and better or
better the rules can change yeah
and improve
the point yeah it improves the point yes
so so slavery is the obvious example so
people always say well
you know why why did it take so long for
christians to decide um to get rid of
slavery that slavery was wrong i mean
christians always thought slavery was
was wrong
um but in the same way that they thought
kind of disease or poverty was wrong but
they just kind of assumed that it was
part of of of what it is to be mortal
it's part of the inheritance of the fall
but what happened in the 18th century
was that again we talked about this very
distinctive protestant idea
understanding of the spirit which is
that you read the text of scripture the
spirit illumines you and um
your understanding of what is written
there will transcend the kind of the the
base meaning
so
the bible nowhere says get rid of
slavery nowhere says slavery is is as an
institution should be abolished but
christians from that protestant
tradition read the scriptures and came
to the conclusion that slavery was was
evil and they did that chiefly because
they were living in societies
that had pushed
the institution of slavery to a kind of
hideously mechanized degree
so
you could put up with you know slavery
where it was two or three people
you know
in a village or something but where
you've got
institutionalized mass torture and and
transportation the horror of it began to
percolate through and to stimulate the
consciences of people who were
witnessing it and furthermore on top of
that it became racialized because
slavery previously hadn't been
racialized um you know there were there
were lots of white slaves in the early
days of the colonies in america but
increasingly um because slaves came to
be exclusively from african that also
served to unsettle the consciences of of
white christians because they knew that
you know they tried to kind of
manufacture reasons why why africans
should be enslaved and and
europeans should be the masters but they
couldn't really do it and and so the
strain of that ultimately enabled um
first quakers and then evangelicals to
convince themselves that god was against
slavery and then having done that to
agitate and push for its abolition and
the the abolitionist movement really is
the model for for for every
socially concerned progressive movement
that has followed since it kind of you
know it in in in 1814 um mass agitation
across britain
forced the foreign secretary lord castle
ray at the congress of vienna after the
defeat of napoleon in 1814 to go there
and even though he didn't want to do it
it was kind of like theresa may having
to go and argue for brexit even though
she didn't want to do it she had to same
way castle ray had to because he had
this mass agitation going on behind him
in london
and across the country to go and ask all
the other powers we've got to get rid of
slavery you know you've got to sign up
to it
um and
you know that that's that's kind of the
model and and and which of us would want
to live in a world where slavery was
morally acceptable so
you know it's
but at the same time
um that there is a kind of temptation i
suppose where um you you can end up
being in love with your own feeling of
virtue
and that that is also you know that's a
temptation i think that that that that
people who are are pushing progressive
causes always have to be alert to and
and that's something that christians
historically have always been aware
they've always contemplated that they
might be sinners themselves that that
that that to be overly convinced of your
own virtue is in itself you know to
cease to be virtuous and i think that
the the the collapse of doctrinal
christianity the the retreat of overt
belief the collapse of doctrines like uh
original sin
have kind of bred perhaps a a degree of
moral
overconfidence on the part of people who
feel that they are furthering
progressive causes
[Music]